[Musica]
giacomo oggi a otto anni sin da piccolo
prova subito sensazioni ed esperienze
che a volte non si provano in una vita
intera
cosa si può fare quando si hanno a
disposizione carte non scelte e
oltretutto ci si trova in una situazione
decisamente avversa si è di fronte ad
una sfida e la si dovrà affrontare solo
utilizzando le carte che si hanno a
disposizione e giacomo in maniera del
tutto spontanea in maniera naturale
riesce ad armonizzarsi ad amalgamarsi in
una realtà complessa una realtà che di
normale ha ben poco
lui si trova ad essere responsabile lui
dimostra di portare a termine tutti i
compiti che gli vengono assegnati e lo
fa in maniera molto precisa in maniera
meticolosa d'altronde lui non vuole
creare dei problemi dove già ne vede
abbastanza empatico lui capisce al volo
quando qualcuno si trova in difficoltà
d'altronde lui stesso molto spesso è
testimone di situazioni complicate
situazioni difficili da gestire e
altruista
lui vorrebbe sempre aiutare tutti quelli
che hanno bisogno di aiuto
a lui viene naturale farlo è tollerante
accetta sempre di aspettare il suo turno
senza mai lamentarsi anche anche solo
per ricevere le attenzioni che vorrebbe
l'attenzione che vorrebbe un bambino
della sua età e tutte queste qualità lo
portano ad essere estremamente resilient
e lui affronta tutte le difficoltà senza
mai abbattersi anzi trova sempre la
strategia giusta e adatta al momento e
grazie alla resilienza lui si sente
estremamente sicuro di sé
d'altronde lui tutti i giorni alla
dimostrazione di essere un grande punto
di riferimento per il fratello autistico
lui
prova soddisfazione quando riesce a
convincere il fratello a cambiare strada
capire una frase mal pronunciata dal
fratello che nessun altro riesce a
comprendere prova soddisfazione quando
riesce a tranquillizzarlo in un momento
in cui il fratello è particolarmente
agitato in questi giorni di isolamento
in cui i bambini si trovano spesso in
classe a passare l'intervallo seduti al
banco giacomo mi ha chiesto un
quadernino un quadernino per i suoi
pensieri nelle gounod l'autismo non
significa che il bambino deve essere
ignorato anzi i genitori passano più
tempo con lui i miei genitori passano
più tempo con mio fratello ma giocano
anche con me tutte queste qualità però
non lo escludono a provare anche
sentimenti contrastanti sentimenti
difficili da capire e soprattutto per un
bambino lui prova rabbia
uffa la mamma non mi può portare al
parco la mamma deve accompagnare mio
fratello terapia prova tristezza
mio fratello cosa del tablet tutto il
giorno mentre a me lo concedono solo
ogni tanto prova impotenza come posso
aiutare mio fratello oggi è
particolarmente agitato solo perché si
ha fulminato una lampadina prova invidia
tutti quelli che vengono a casa nostra
chiedono come sta mio fratello chiedono
come procedono le sue terapie i suoi
progressi di ma se ne infischiano
proprio a 37 anni ho avuto il mio primo
figlio nicolò a 39 ho avuto il mio
secondo figlio giacomo a 40 anni ho
ricevuto la diagnosi di autismo del mio
primo figlio un figlio autistico ti
stravolge la vita
ma anche avere un fratello autistico
tela stravolge i fratelli dei bambini
disabili sono anche vulnerabili sono un
facile bersaglio sotto l'aspetto del
bullismo tuo fratello e proprio scemo
tuo fratello non capisce niente solo per
avere un fratello disabile succede
succede anche questo purtroppo è in
mezzo a una pandemia mondiale in un
periodo in cui di normale c'è veramente
poco
giacomo è stato invitato ad andare alla
lavagna dalla sua insegnante a parlare
ai suoi compagni dell'autismo a parlare
di suo fratello a parlare della
disabilità e l'ha fatto con una
naturalezza disarmante e si è
aggiudicato addirittura l'applauso da
tutti i compagni
io sapevo perché avevo letto che una
grande percentuale di persone
confratelli disabili poi da grande
svolge un lavoro che a che fare quella
disabilità
sembrava una cosa assurda impossibile ma
come uno ha una disabilità in casa tutti
i giorni in famiglia e poi se la vuole
ritrovare anche sul posto di lavoro
poi però pensato beh d'altronde infine
dei musicisti praticano suono degli
strumenti i figli degli sportivi
praticano dello sport quindi direi che
l'ambiente esterno condizione a chiunque
e una mattina una mattina come tante
giacomo mi ha stupito ancora una volta
dicendomi mamma io so già cosa farò da
grande io farò l'insegnante di sostegno
perché sono già capace a farlo grazie